hello guys and welcome to another video
in this video we have some news
regarding the future of spider-man more
specifically regarding andrew garfield
spider-man now before we get into this
video there will be spoilers for
spider-man no way home so if you haven't
seen the film then click off this video
now with that out of the way let's get
straight into the video so we all know
that andrew garfield's performance and
spiderman no way home was just
breathtaking and the scene where he
saves mj was just beautiful and he
finally got some redemption to his
character we've heard from some leakers
that this is not the last we'll see of
toby and andrew and that apparently
andrew garfield could actually come back
for multiple projects another credible
leaker said i also hear andrew might
come back now you're probably wondering
if he does come back in what capacity
what film will it be in now there's
actually a trend on twitter where it
says
make the amazing spider-man 3 happened
now i think it's completely possible
that we'll actually get a third film for
an amazing spider-man um and we also
hear that andrew might come back for
multiple projects now what i personally
think will happen is um andrew garfield
spider-man will show up in the third
venom film now we know tom hardy's
character eddie brock was um transported
back to his universe at the end of
spider-man no way home in the end
credits scene so i think it's entirely
possible that they could make um the
sony universe crossover with andrew
garfield spider-man and tom hardy in the
third random film now this could be a
great way to test the waters now let's
say andrew garfield is in a third random
film that stays received very very well
then potentially sonia marvel will look
at this and say all right andrew
garfield's character has been received
really well no way home and the third
random film let's give him his own solo
movie being the amazing spider-man 3.
now i would be all for this personally i
want to see him get the closure that he
deserves i want to see his trilogy i'm
completed with the third film but wait
guys that's about it for this video
nothing too concrete but we're hearing a
lot of stuff from leakers that andrew
garfield may return and a lot of social
media buzz going around with people
doing hashtag make the amazing
spider-man 3 happen which surely this
get the word out to sony and marvel that
we want to see his character return so
what do you guys think of this news do
you think he will return and if he does
return what do you want to see from his
character let me know in the comment
section below and also if you enjoyed
the video please like and subscribe and
turn notifications on to show your
support thanks for watching guys